quand elles entrent ici richman athlètes
en terrain conquis
dans ce congrès syndical on souligne
passées d'avocats spécialisé en droit du
travail de la chef du npd sa fin
j'entends l'énergique alors qu'ils
étaient travailleurs c'est ce que l'on
peut dire que oui toujours note les 51
ans à la politique et le npd dans le
sang son père guen note lee et le
premier néo démocrates avoir remporté un
siège dans une élection générale en
alberta chef du parti pendant 15 ans il
est mort tragiquement dans un écrasement
d'avion en 1984 près de trente ans plus
tard sa fille a été élu à la tête de ce
parti qui ne comptait que quatre députés
avant le déclenchement des élections
ruptures note les ne mise pas que sur
ses racines pour gagner la confiance des
albertains pour séduire l'électorat elle
parle de défendre des services de
qualité en santé et en éducation
celles qui misent sur le mécontentement
à l'endroit des conservateurs se pose à
l'impopulaire taxe santé annoncée dans
le budget de mars
sa popularité et sa bonne performance au
débat des chefs ont fait de ruptures
note les l'ennemi numéro 1 des
progressistes conservateurs en quête
d'une 13e majorités consécutives
le npd qui veut augmenter de 2% les pour
les grandes entreprises nuire à
l'économie selon jim prentice message
que les militants conservateurs
martèlent en entrevue et sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis des jours
rich iott les a aussi affirmé qu'elle
n'encourage ray pas le controversé
projet d'oléoduc notre ghetto et qui
doit relier l'alberta à l'océan
pacifique
il faut quand même répondre aux réalités
économiques de l'alberta et ça les
réalités économiques
c'est qu'il faut plus de pipelines pour
pour avoir plus de marché pour nos
produits à ottawa aussi on suit les
faits et gestes de ritchot notes et ses
troupes se montre tout le potentiel pour
le parti à travers le canada et je suis
ravi même si tout le monde est très
prudent à l'endroit des sondages la
grande famille néo démocrates espèrent
beaucoup voire reach on note les
ébranler les fondations du temple
progressiste conservateur en alberta ici
rappelle bouvier oakley radio canada
edmonton